oh I should change this hello reject
nation Greg Alva here and it's John here
so one of our rewards on patreon
whatever exclusive rewards whatever
video you request will there be a
reaction or a discussion we must
definitely do this we're doing it it's
not a reaction that's been requested ooh
it is top 10 favorite game of Thrones
care well honestly it's Rosa Park Rosa
Parra yes her before she's the lady we
visited her and her family in that
special vlog we did Rosa wanted us to do
our tots and a favorite game of Thrones
episodes and I was like ah we're gonna
hold people I don't really remember
every episode I can't break it down so I
was like is there anybody we could do
like top 10 favorite game of Thrones
characters and rake that and she said
that's fine as long as Game of Thrones
related so Jon and I spent a good 40
minutes come contemplating who should
and shouldn't be on this list and now we
have narrowed it down to our 10 to our
mutual favorites and if you are not
happy with this objective list let us
know you know what to do let us know
because that's what you game with
Thrones fans do when you don't like
something at all you just you gotta rip
us apart right don't worry we'll
definitely read those comments always Oh
always read always get your identity
based off those comments anyway John you
and I do this I'm ready to do this
number 10 number 10 on our list on our
little professionalist listing videos we
have number 10 of Cersei Cersei
Lannister
you guys know Cersei Lannister you know
as much as we could try to sound like
the intellectual film dance well just
tell you why we love these characters
instead what I love about Cersei
I suspect what's the actresses name
again Lena Headey Lena Headey what is
that the girl from girl alas - Lena
Dunham yeah
very different yeah but she complains to
Playland their smell like Tommen's yeah
what I love about her performance is
it's so multi-layer like everyone else
on that show
she's very multi-layered this show had
is a fascinating effect where you go
back and forth between every character
Cersei is that character who I don't
always hate more often than not I hate
her however she has this ability where
every once in a while I'm very
sympathetic for the lady well I
understand where she's coming from she
knows how to one-up every time you think
she's at the bottom of the pit every
time you think there's she doesn't have
a fighting chance she figures out a wait
a minute it's be laid her way up there
or get someone else to help her out
where she can come out on top she is a
worthwhile enemy that they have built up
to this final season it's like yes
there's the walkers and then the yeah
yeah there's you know the DEA
there's Cersei if I was Jamie yeah maybe
I'd be conflicted ah I'll leave it on
that note
yeah yeah well we talked about having a
villain on this list you know cuz it's
hard to claim the villain sometimes this
is one of your favorite characters and
we've there are some good villains on
Game of Thrones we've talked about you
know you have to talk about like Joffrey
and Ramsay but those dudes are you know
just kind of like evil yeah plus
Osteopathic and like surprise he's too
close to home for me I relate too much
Aransas you know I feel for the guy but
yeah Cersei had that quality of like I
get I get I get you but yeah she's a
maddening character but she's also
really compelling and of all the
villains I think she is the most
compelling number nine number nine
number nine is Sandor Clegane aka the
hound talk about a character who has
arched and growing over time guy you
wanted dead for a while and now you're
like no this guy this is one of the best
he says see you next Tuesday better than
anyone else
he does he does does catchphrase yeah
yeah he says like that it's not the
acronym it's it's the furnace see you
next Tuesday with an S EE and feather
hounds awesome because yeah for a
character called the Hound
is kind of like that angry dog who you
can see is just a really hurt boy on the
inside yeah I think it's a beautiful
thing about that guy's performance is
he's big he's nasty he's ruthless
however you can see that he's really
just a hurt boy he is like a dog on the
inside you know and there's something
I've always found really authentic about
just that character in the way he plays
that game yeah right and he's a great
reminder to me of it's easy to get lost
in whoo in westeros in all these
different realms and stuff and to feel
what the true scope of it is and we
watch this guy travel to and meet so
many different characters and kind of
weave throughout the show and touch a
lot of different plot lines and I think
that's really cool and I think he's
really compelling subplot character for
those reasons yeah I mean he's yeah I
think when ah really he's a guy who
started off villainous and then you
really grow to like hope he turns into a
good guy and it seems like the show is
really taking him into good guy
direction part of the thing when I
started this show is like watching Ned
Stark I was like man you just you know
you're gonna I know you're gonna just
seems like you're not meant for this
world and yeah and like Clegane has
grown in ways were it's like he's still
pragmatic and still kind of gruff enough
to make it here but also he's like
really developing a sense of humanity
humanity yeah the character model that
for me varies number eight number eight
Varys the spider I had to look up what a
eunuch meant because of this guy believe
it and I didn't know it and then I
watched read watch parts of the
Caribbean with you this year and I was
like oh every time he says you're not
they makes eunuch jokes that's what it
means
yeah funny jazz Jack Sparrow means no
junk
let's move out our number seven now
barry's is compelling and a lot of those
same ways too because I personally hated
the guy the first time you know that
villainous way of talking like him and
Baelish thing to really balance each
other out at a very strong perspective
and then one there's that one episode he
gives this whole monologue as to who is
what his backstory is how he came to be
here and that's when I think for not
just myself but a lot of people the
perception of who this guy his the
vastly changed
he's more on this list for John than me
I'll give of that however I like him
enough to be like yeah let's put him on
the list it's easy
argue for Baelish too and it's like I
feel like you know the the you know the
hands I just think a little fingers a
little too OneNote well yeah that's the
only reason I did are you for him
because me yeah like he's a fun
character to watch but he does have kind
of a very visible does that actor yeah I
think yeah it's not amazing or scorched
rather than like yeah oh you seem
trustworthy but the audience can always
tell you're not a knight yeah Jing High
Knights in video it varies I think for
the beginning I like that character cuz
like even though he again every
character sort of starts one way you get
to perceive them from the outside and
then you start to get to know them and
you know make your a new conclusion from
there and like Varys is a character I
trust now and there are a few of those
you know on the show but also um I've
always thought he was a good example of
like the good gray in the advisors to
the you know Royals and stuff those
parts are compelling to me when it's
about the people who are advising the
kings and queens and the generals and
stuff the people who were like really
digging animation doing the work that
informs you know what they're you know
yes stroke administration exactly no I
just I just really enjoy both his
performance just you know his mannerisms
and stuff and also the story of that
character and the Alliance's he's built
over time assembling Daenerys is a squad
I'm glad Varys made the team you know it
made me a fan happy sir Bronn of the
Blackwater as number seven man he's my
homeboy honestly he's just my homeboy
his storyline is not the most compelling
so that's why it's a higher up on this
list
yeah but out of characters whenever
they're on screen I am just having a
good time he's that guy he's one of the
closest things to comic relief of the
show you'll yeah something like Game of
Thrones well because he's an oddly
loveable rascal you're like yeah I know
there's a lot of stuff about you that's
not great and no one tells it how it is
like bran true them he always tells it
how it is and if he's lying or being
deceitful he kind of just puts it out
there too he's just so funny he's got no
time to horse around he's just a
survivor yeah
love that aspect of him and how he like
climbs the ranks he wants more at the
same time it's like he might sell out
and do something like a little bit more
that doesn't give in to the good side of
his heart every once in a while but you
can tell he's like like in the season 7
episode when they all come together the
big who and all the characters finally
meet each other you know when Braun's
interacting with Tyrion you know like
there's still that sense of
understanding that even though bran is
on you know Cersei and Jaime side he
still respects Tyrion a lot you know and
I love those aspects to the guy and I
never want him to die I know he's so
funny yeah well that's a character the
two is very distinct for those reasons
because that's that was one of my
favorite moments in the recent season
was seeing especially through bran you
know cuz he's been with a number of
different characters we've followed and
so to see him chat with both John and
Tyrion just like their old friend like
regardless the guy can put down you know
the bigger picture just be like yeah I
like you you know I think the writers do
a great job with him in terms of
bouncing out without letting him get too
sensitive ever like there was a scene
that they deleted that we saw clip of
the episode when Shay is being told by
Tyrion to leave and then he kind of
explains a lot to Shane he gets a lot
more sympathetic and heartfelt while it
was kind of a nice deleted scene as I'm
kind of glad it wasn't in the episode
though because it puts them too much on
the softer side when I'm like I like
that they don't let bran go too far
there ever
I feel like bran is not the type of
character to do anything out of altruism
but like he does save Jamie's life at
one point you're like it's just like
it's his actions it's not his words yeah
words or you got to keep tough bran yeah
Jon Snow bastard saw stood Sun not Stark
not anymore isn't no Lord Commander of
the Nights Watch this is like a beatles
over older one snow you know I wanted to
be him for Halloween but I'm like I
can't be Johnson those season 1 hair I
mean it's my hair is pretty long very
white is white Johnson yeah straighten
and then type is there's curly well you
could straighten it a little
this is the steep the look is he has
curly hair I don't know how to make my
hair fall like is that's like my hair
can I can make it long enough and bring
it out to be season one Johnson but I'm
like who wants to be season one Jon Snow
so instead you must love it so I'm gonna
be the most beloved character of all the
defenders instead iron fist cuz that's a
unique no one's gonna be him Jon Snow he
is the closest thing to Ned Stark's
heart that we have on this show what I
love about him he is the leader of the
show in a lot of ways like he doesn't
start off the show like a leader but I
love the art that he's had where he is
becoming the main leader
cuz he's constantly making choices that
involve sacrifice that involve
navigation foresight that other people
cannot see he got killed at one point
because of it even though it was the
right decision in the long term he
thinks long-term about things he thinks
about the bigger scope and I appreciate
that a lot about his character like even
when he's making the decision to bend
the knee to Daenerys it it's like this
ain't gonna go down well but he knows
this is the best thing to do and in
terms of kid herring the one actor whose
name I know kid Harrington turns up to
his performance at first I didn't see
what the huge deal was about Jon Snow
like the first couple seasons I'm like
why does everyone love this guy so I
like him he's likable definitely but I
don't know lovely Jon Snow he's you're
alright a dog but over the course of the
seasons you see that he has like the
greatest heart it's like there's one
person on the show you want to be it's
Jon Snow like the kind of ideal human
being I'd like to be it's Jon Snow a
lethal fighter a great leader a man
who's caught does his best to constantly
be compassionate and understanding
thinks about the bigger picture he's
everything I'd want to be as a man you
know he's loyal yeah in the breakdown of
things he is perhaps of mathematically
the best yeah tour which is why he's
number six and I feel like women would
want a man like Jon Snow to well yeah
because he's 62 he's sexy you know he's
a it's not that he's not a virgin
anymore but he doesn't seem like he's
like interested in like you know I'm
still young I gotta get laid off
yeah I use that for that dude no it's
like even he has sex when he's in love
what woman who doesn't want this guy
yeah yeah yeah you know naturally I
think he just rises to the top of that
show because he is the best leader of
all the leader yeah watching traveling
out the world it's like yeah he's a bomb
yeah Jorah Mormont or Jorah the Andal if
you're a Dothraki sea please come easy
Khaleesi it was when I saw that that was
this quote that I was like he's my
favorite character yeah Khaleesi please
godly seasons I'm like this is crazy yes
every other line listen to me cuz we see
six whole seasons give this guy a break
yeah yeah and I just feel sorry for
Jorah cuz he's like older and he really
wants to be with Daenerys was like dude
you're too much older you're like well
don't have to be your dad man yeah it's
not falling in love with her yeah I get
out of love man cuz it ain't gonna
happen I feel very sorry for the guy you
know it's like he's one of those guys
who wears his heart on his sleeve you
can tell he's a guy who has a lot of
regrets he's been through a hell of it
like so much is the water of life yeah
you could tell he's been through so much
pain and he's made decisions he is not
proud exactly well I love about his
characters he works as hard on his
shoulders and he's so expression it in
his eyes and more importantly you don't
really know a whole lot about Joris
backstory you know you know some stuff
about Joris backstory of course what I
love about that actor's performance you
can feel an entire history with this guy
hey he really feels like he's in
whatever this national world is he's too
good at it he's listen to good super
lived-in and he's there earnest
yeah that he's very understanding he
doesn't really seem to get to a rageful
point at least on the outside even
though you could feel there's like a
month there's not a monster but a
rageful guy in and there's a war he's a
warrior
yeah who's had to do some things were it
made him feel ashamed and that guilt and
shame kind of guides him and I feel like
there's so much relatable to Jorah
without it being expositional
that's what I really appreciate about
his character oh yeah because you can
identify with his struggle because he is
just a guy who's trying to do better
yeah especially like that's kind of I
guess part of the bread and butter of
the show is what do the folks who just
want to do better do we in a situation
and especially in the Khaleesi in the
Daenerys storyline like he's one of my
favorite parts of that so Oh easily
number four Jaime Lannister Jaime
Lannister man Han Jae Nicolas revolver
winshuttle whatever his name is
Nikolaj coster-waldau well done you have
you're right we'll never know because we
won't i MJ and I don't know what to do
with them this character is probably the
most impressive to me in terms of how
he's been handled over the season easily
what wouldn't bring come in third season
half weight like it yeah well before
before his journey with bran when his
character really started to shift I
hated this guy Yeah right
did this guy yeah I was just like I that
was he was one of my he was on my list
yeah and then some people would tell me
like don't worry later now in the
seasons you grow to like him
oh yeah like could I ever like this guy
after all the wrong things he's done to
my characters we loved him and then ever
that speech she gives the lady Stark
about like you know I'm more loyal than
Ned was because Jon's a bastard and I've
only been with Cersei yeah this guy
knows how to get under your skin
and then as those lands the show goes on
you know when they start to reveal more
of his humanity that like you know this
guy he's not just some like guy who just
wants more power wants to be at the top
it's a weird subject because it deals
with incest but you can tell this guy
just loves this woman yeah he's just
really in love with this woman yeah
that's all he cares about and that's a
the in a day and age where you know you
see a lot of similar things that's a
feeling I don't get to explore a lot and
I'm like I don't know how to feel about
you I get it yes I get it but also know
you know he's become someone who's very
compassionate and he has some little
guest a way that lives with the guilt to
allow these characters to guilt the
performance of this actor
become so strong in the area where he's
become one of those characters like I
trust and I respect him he's charismatic
I like him and I like the struggle of
when he lost his hand and he had to
rebuild this reputation and keep growing
and like the specific French if she's
developed or the someone like brawn with
Brienne and how he's the only one who
seemed to like Tyrion you know yeah we
seem to give him any time of day he is
really really grown as a character in
such a way that even conflicts with his
central romance you know it's now like
watching the way he talks to Cersei now
versus before like the last moments like
there are times when I miss him in a
season because sometimes like lately he
doesn't pop up that much but every time
he does yeah it's a good scene and his
relationship with his sister mines are a
lot of your relationship with your
sister
Thanks number three on our list three is
Arya Stark
Arya Stark are is stark the youngest of
the stark daughters you know I didn't
like Arya the first few seasons when
everyone was like Arya is so cool I
loved her story I'm like I don't I
always felt like REO was in this like
storyline where everyone around her was
super interesting okay like when she's
with the Hound the Hound is super
interesting when she's under Tywin when
new and she's are there certain servant
for a little while Tywin she was too you
know and then when she's with i learning
to be a person with no man with no face
yeah like that guy's more interesting
once it got to I think I think it was
season six when we got to season six or
or season five whenever she was really
going through the training I finally
started grasping what everyone was
talking about she really does have a
very specific journey that she's on this
little girl who has like fire two
qualities in sight I've got spunk but
they really commit to it to the point
where you know like I see shows like
arrow where Oliver Queen is stuck on an
island for four years or four to five
years and then he goes through training
through various people and now he's the
most lethal weapon in all of America I'm
always like questioning it even like
Batman Begins makes me go he only
trained for like six years why is he
better than everyone else who's been
training there since they were children
he didn't have to go to work or make
money with this show though yeah with
Aria they're so detailed in her journey
that you want by the time you you get to
this point in the season I'm like yeah I
believe it i watch you go through a so
much more than just traumatic
experiences he meant there all types of
training to the point where my dad could
believe you as this person of multiple
skills I like how she's grown into a a
killer with a heart you might be able to
argue that with some other characters
but she seems that the light when she
gets to kill someone on that list
she's bloodthirsty I hate to you yes she
likes it she enjoys it you know and I
like seeing this kind of dark somewhat
like serial killer on the inside is a
lethal warrior but yeah really cares
about good people though yeah hears
about kind people but she loves to kill
back I guess in the best direction yeah
yeah yeah I really I really like that
about her and beyond her skills she's
become this character who handles her
dialogue incredibly well like when she
is talking in a menacing way or being
threatening I believe that girl yeah
because she doesn't have to go too far
into into telegraphing it you know I
feel like she's good at pulling it back
and being subtle about it yeah she talks
very calmly yeah and almost unassumingly
there's always like a hint of that and
it's gripping EJ you could always see
there's something else going on inside
she's not saying you could tell there's
she's thinking something else as well
she's the observant one of the show yeah
that'd mean next to like someone like a
Tyrion she's observing in her own way
and she's resourceful you know I've
grown a really lover and even at the
times when I didn't love her a character
because of where I saw her character go
made me appreciate everything that came
prior to that so yeah she's definitely
one of the top three favorites that's
for damn sure
number two on the list all right I love
this character so I hope that we both
agree on it number two for me is Brienne
of Tarth she's cool Michael all right no
I hate her I hate her my least favorite
is my least favorite why isn't she a man
she's got all those chemicals relevant
qualities out of why why did I get a
woman hyung comments on how tall she is
gender Miska how good at least make it
part of her character breakdown now what
is this now yeah I love Brienne and I
kind of feel like they've left her out a
little too much in the last yeah it was
a bummer see I feel that way especially
because she was a big part of me really
coming to enjoy the show because it took
me a little while to get hooked and the
first season you know was a little bit
like okay I appreciate what this isn't
and then for a little further on it was
like all right I'm starting to enjoy it
but she was one of the first characters
that I was like yeah yeah I want to keep
watching your story and you're really
compelling me to come back to the show
overall you know yeah because she is one
of the more tried and true you know
moral characters yeah and her backstory
really helps her out a lot you know cuz
they're like her physicality has caused
her to become judged so much and she's
his character who is traumatized from
being bullied and made fun of for all
these things I think what makes her so
admirable as a character she's someone
who's embraced these qualities that is
that she got like made fun of so much
about and is now it's really dangerous
woman she's a strong fighter who just
doesn't give up and then really shows
especially in terms of action sequences
that fight that she has with that happen
but with that hound with uh with the
Hound of legend
yeah that hound that actual dog she
fought yeah that fight scene is it was a
really special one because that's a
fight where she is struggling but she
doesn't quit she doesn't give up I love
how her character someone who's so
closed off is all about loyalty to the
hierarchy yet she goes through conflicts
of questioning of what she's been told
you know she develops a heart for Jaime
someone who was just a prisoner and then
when she is following her loyalty you
know there's someone like when she's
looking after Sansa looking at anything
going after Arya and her relationship
that she forms with Podrick so I don't
want this guy here everybody that's here
because their purpose yeah he is what
Brienne is tonight's and stuff yeah he
is to being a squire yeah yeah yeah I
think they're the perfect combination
and that and that was like a good
fanservice moment for me cuz I was like
oh two of my favorite day
adventure and her performance is
phenomenal on the show she is truly
phenomenal on the show well what's a RZA
know with her character over time is
like yeah you you meet her and she's a
bit more like rigid and by the rules and
stuff like that but over time you do
start to learn that conflict you know
like you said the whole thing where
people kind of treat her terribly all
the time like nobody kind of gets where
she belongs in this world but you really
start to see the conviction and the
fight you know because it's like she
doesn't ever crumble to these people you
could tell it affects her you know and
she feels out of place and that's why
you know those kingships with I feel
like that's part of what that kinship
with Jamie kind of is because they're
both in very opposite ways outside the
norm and I feel like over time she
develops that moral compass where it's
like it's not about the system so much
as like I got to do what's right and
they've gotta be by that people you know
and I got the fight to do it she's tough
as nails man
what's cool about her is like a lot of
times you're gonna get like tough female
roles it can be hard to make it like
that are a lady who's also really tough
I don't know if you know what I mean but
yeah she's still a lady and I use that
word specifically you know not just a
female character but a it's just a
female character who does and acts the
way tough dudes do yeah yeah yeah and
her looks too it's like yeah I mean she
has a short haircut she's tall a little
stocky but she's also it's passable for
being a knight yeah I don't look at her
as just like some butch woman like she
is still is just so feminine in her yeah
that's normally I don't know why I can't
cover my feminine is the word I'm
looking for
yes feminine yeah cuz there is a certain
you know she still has a sexuality and
stuff like that and they're even they
even take time in later season to have
characters be like do ya about her yeah
it doesn't like torment and either right
in our century all about is the real
actresses creators
number one number ten Terry Tyrion
Lannister
Tyrion Lannister Peter Dinklage I know
his name peter dinklage peter dinklage
peter day good night good night
that's all you know that song the Dinks
to me Tyrion other than the being able
to fight aspect which at one point he
does have a moment in he has a couple
moments where he gets to kill and pretty
like awesome ways even when he kills his
dad on the toilet you're like tyrion
style man I like it yeah yeah he is the
embodiment I feel of what I love about
all these characters yeah like he's a
straw like his inner qualities are a
huge mixture of everyone that we've just
talked about you know cuz he does have
that thing we're in the beginning of the
show like this is an unlikable dude I
don't like I don't like this guy and
then he oh he can also be very
manipulative and cunning but he's also
items but then over the time you see all
these other stronger qualities he's
super charming he's super funny he's the
most observant one he's someone who's
been bullied a lot with a lot of trauma
in his past but he's used that to his
advantage now
well he's become very practical and very
resourceful and good reader of people
yeah exactly and he also has things he
feels really guilty about that way on
his heart and shoulders just beat him
being born is a weight he has to bear so
I feel like he has like literally a
nanny and also too he's consistently
grown more into a character with a heart
who's very compassionate less about
being cunning yet he still knows how to
use all these qualities he's this guy
who is everyone on this list to me yeah
all the qualities on the list yeah I
think everybody on this list the one
thing that unites them all is I think
most of these characters are misfits are
outsiders in some way they're the
outsider characters of different either
families or storylines or all all of
that above perhaps the most expansive
and most gripping example of that growth
yeah
I think I had the reaction to him that
you had to to maybe John or somebody
where I was like I don't get why
everybody loves this character yeah and
then it took me a while to be like yeah
yeah it's like I mean you are one of my
very favorites yeah I'm always happy to
well if you see like bran like look at
look at these listed characters I mean a
character like Jamie
grows from someone who you hate into
someone you love he's got that if you
look at Brienne this character who gets
bullied a lot in her past for being born
in her physicality the way she is yeah
she's got that and also you know she
liked bran and Podrick and Tyrion and
Podrick in the beginning now there was
that bran the charming tell it how it is
aspect very since Cersei their
manipulation negotiation types of
tactics he's got that too and then Jamie
knowing how to like do battle and lead
and navigate he's got that he's got her
and then being and then the the other
like Jamie loses a hand and that makes
him have a physical Blair's like oh yeah
there's like a kind of a parallel there
or there's a lot of forbiddens and a lot
of like things that we shun Varys is a
eunuch and Jon Snow is a bastard Clegane
has that whole you know awful
relationship with his brother and find a
PTSD thing you know yeah yeah definitely
same thing we talked about with Cole
gain had been like a hurt boy on the
inside you could totally feel that with
Tyrion yeah that he's he's a boy on the
inside he's a hurt boy and Jon with with
with the guy with the heart who put his
life at risk to do the right thing for
someone he's grown into that person -
yeah yeah yeah so he's a he's an all
easy embodiment of everything and you
know one thing I got to give credit to
you for Peter Dinklage on this role it's
a thing that they consistently point out
throughout the seasons you know he's a
dwarf he's a dwarf that's what they
could they constantly say in the
beginning of the show I was like oh he's
the dwarf character you know like that's
what he is he's the dwarf got him and
every time I see Peter Dinklage he's the
little man that's what they always point
out and they make it very specific he's
the little man over time pretty fast you
stop thinking like he's a little man
look at that pointed out i've wondered -
cuz there are bald writing aspects you
know that that that scene where he's
being put up by trial by his dad yeah
he's like I am guilty yeah that moment
is standing up to everyone
wonderful in any possible way as I have
no idea with the real Peter Dinklage is
like not a clue to his backstory where
he's from I don't know anything about
mostly but I wonder for someone who's
born as a little man if that is
something where that was semi
therapeutic to do character like this mm
there's there's something of that but
yes I mean you know we we're an
authenticity weird form it's you know
yeah and I feel like we as a society are
still on the journey of accepting and
just understanding little pieces like I
know a few little people and like
usually bother to kind of shed a light
on the issues so I feel like there is a
lot of stuff that we're not aware of yet
yeah you know or at least is we don't
know how to think about those are our
top 10 list people yeah honestly
my favorite character of all time is not
someone even recommended for this list
the only reason I didn't put him on the
list is because he's he's only in one
season
and that's Ned Stark Ned Ned Stark he is
known as Father Stark
you know he's father started he's a
priest presents seven seasons later know
strongly resonant in the show yeah still
really felt the thing though is the
reason I don't want phone list is
because I'm like chilling one season
yeah the other guys have been in at
least a few seasons yeah you didn't get
I feel like a lot of these characters
have had the benefit of that yeah
because the show does make you
appreciate and notice because we've been
doing this for years and that's one
thing that's magic about still having to
wait for TV is like the time passes with
you yeah and so yeah it's like we've
grown up with this family and and Ned
Stark is a weird position because it's
like you're deaf kind of kicks this all
off it is you know like are you guys
here is the one who I always felt the
like I always felt warm and fuzzy and
safe when Ned was around you know so
that's why it was a great plot move yeah
on George RR Martin's part to the guy
it was too good for this whoa good for
the world and I'm sure there's like
other characters you guys probably
wondering your name Melisandre I'm sure
we'll get a lot of guff for not
including dinner
what about Drogo weird rogue on our Davo
say like don't give it like torment this
isn't a list of characters we don't like
alright this isn't to fly than every
other character we don't yeah okay these
are just and then we thought what if we
just rank all the Game of Thrones
characters or like rank the houses and
how you get a rink like a reoccurring
character who was there for a few
episodes but only in one season
yeah Tommen Tommen's near the time yeah
old lady who just died from house Tyrell
Oh
Olenna she did she's amazing Jan tastic
chances are if you're upset this purse
is not on the list we like them too okay
Roz's is cool too anyway guys what did
you think of her list and a positive
ending here did you like it I hope so
subscribe to the real rejects click that
notification bell you can subscribe to
us on patreon.com slash the real rejects
as well if you want to and also check
this guy out at the greg alba on
Instagram and Ed John Humphrey on
Instagram we also are at the real
rejects on Instagram totally confusing
did I miss anything
no because on Instagram we're at real
rejects become a patron objected a Rosa
Parra thank you for the suggestion this
video was a lot of fun to film it's nice
it's nice to get a request for something
that's not a reaction so thank you for
requesting this and I hope you enjoy the
video shouts out to you and your entire
family of daughters especially Cassandra
cause she's the one that loves me